[Music]
all right let's go to tim in des moines
des moines iowa what's up tim
hey john
hey do you call it desmoines or is that
like what lame people call it
uh i think
people who don't speak english cause
that
that was a strong flex tim strong flex i
do speak english
i just think it's funny but i'll call it
des moines
uh so what's up dude how can i help
um
so my question is uh my girlfriend gave
me a
quite serious std and my parents ended
up finding out about this
um they are now against our relationship
saying that it's the way that god is
showing that this relationship is not
meant to be
um i've been fighting this
like against my parents
and my question is has
is there too much that has happened for
this relationship to work
uh or am i trying too hard to make it
work
bro there's a lot going on here man
a whole lot
um
before i dig in let's let me just let's
just have a conversation so i get to
know you for a second is that cool
okay yeah um you sound a little bit
nervous are you nervous or is this just
weird or i realize you're calling a
stranger being like okay i got an st eye
from
this woman that i love this whole
thing's kind of weird
this is basically the first person
outside of this
uh situation that i've talked to so
gotcha
dude i'm i'm grateful for the trust it
sounds like there's a lot lot going on
here
um
tell me about you how old are you what
are you for living all that kind of
stuff
uh
27
going to um
studying nursing okay
and
uh just about to graduate here
so congratulations on that um do you
live at home
no i i don't okay so
what kind of sti did you get
uh hiv okay so you've got hiv okay so i
was wondering if this was
my first question was why in the world
do your parents know
um
if i'm 27 the last people on planet
earth i would call until i have an sti
is my parents but um hiv is super
serious what is your
health prognosis
um it's
um so
i guess the situation gets a little bit
more difficult because
um
my dad does computer diagnostics and he
was able to
accidentally kind of find out i have
this and so i am
accidentally kind of what does that mean
meaning he wasn't expecting it he wasn't
looking for it it was just kind of came
up
when uh he was doing that i regularly do
checkups he's a a doctor oh so he's a
doctor at the place where you went to
get checked out
and
he
discovered through the computer system
that his son has hiv
yes it's it's a it's a
alternative medicine that he
does and
so it's it's a very different kind of
for modern medicine so it's
just
uh
just the way that he found out
i just go to my dad always for health
checkups yeah
oh what a mess okay so tell me about
this person that you're dating
um
so um
i guess what
what would you like to know about her
no just tell me about that
well uh she's a she's a nurse
in uh illinois and
um
this is
the second uh
serious relationship she's had
okay uh for me it's
um
maybe the first serious relationship for
me okay um and so
she's i mean she grew up in a christian
family she's
um
does she knowing you knowingly give you
hiv
no she didn't know about it
okay
is she the first person you've ever
slept with
yes okay
how long y'all been together
uh we've been uh together for a year now
a year okay
so back to my original question brother
this is just me caring about
somebody i just met like what's your
health prognosis
um so
right now there's potential that the
treatment that through my dad that
it will go away even though
um
with
so i'm
being treated for it that way
um
yes in the place where i work there's a
thousand employees here
i would be willing to bet my truck and
it's not a great car i'm gonna be honest
with it's not great but i'd be willing
to bet it
that
i'm the most
health practitioner in this building
i'm not a health practitioner i didn't
say that right that i am the most um
homeopathic geeked out nerd when it
comes to that kind of stuff in this
building right
and you have hiv
and i want you to
make sure you go meet with a traditional
practitioner okay
yeah got it
yes and there's yeah i understand that
less
i don't want you taking essential oils
and like fermented oats and with the
assumption that hiv is going to go away
right okay and i'm being provocative and
i know that and my friends who are
homeopaths are going to get all over me
i get that
um i don't want you to mess around with
this okay
right
right
um that's a secondary thing
so
to answer your original question brother
i i don't want to get into
faith disagreements with you and with
your parents
i do not believe that
god has given you a terminal illness
because you had premarital sex if that's
the question
but i also am not going to get into a
debate with somebody who has that
particular faith view that's not that's
not an a fight i'm interested in
engaging
um you did have unprotected sex with
somebody right
and
a
consequence of unprotected sex can be
stis
and
can be hiv is that right
okay
so
i want to deal with where you are right
now
um
you're 28 27 is that right
yep
so at the end of the day your parents do
not get a vote on who you're dating
do you live at home
i don't i already asked you that no you
don't so they don't get a vote brother
yes
um
is your relationship with the woman that
you love who gave you hiv gonna be
fraught with
so much trauma yeah
is it gonna be
hard to work through that yeah no
question about that
can you i
i've never honestly sat down with
somebody who's in your situation i have
talked to folks numerous folks who got
things like syphilis or gonorrhea or
something like that i have not talked
through somebody in this situation
talked through a bajillion of couples
who get pregnant and their parents are
are all over them
haven't talked to somebody with
something as serious as this
and my understanding of where we
currently are with in the medical system
with hiv is limited i know there's some
cocktails and stuff that have proven to
be rather remarkable
um
but i i don't know anything about your
medical condition and
like
how what prognosis is how long you have
to live all that kind of stuff
what i'll tell you is
um
it is not uncommon
for somebody
to feel intimately connected to the
first person they're with despite trauma
despite anything despite a all those
things
so your love for her your
connection to her
is
yours um
let me what are you asking me
um
like am i am i just disregarding the
situation and trying to make something
work that
is not meant to work
i don't think you can i don't think
that's a question worth asking
yeah
i think the question worth asking is
do you want to be with somebody who gave
you hiv
whether unknowingly or knowingly
do you want to be with somebody
who um
does that person treats you i mean it's
all all the normal stuff
does that make sense
yeah
does this person um make you feel whole
does this person make you feel like you
have value does this person love you and
has dedicated their life to serving you
and vice versa
or
are you bonding over trauma and tragedy
oh crap we're in this we might as well
be together forever and make it work at
all cost et cetera
i gotcha i'm telling you
i would have a
heart on this side of the fence again
i've never been on the inside
dating somebody for seven months eight
months and then finding out they gave me
hiv
i would have a hard time leaning into
that relationship
again that is me on this side of it
if i happen to be in that situation i
can't speak to it because i don't have
that experience
but if you walk in going is this meant
to be should i am i wasting my time dude
i can't answer that question for you why
do you want to stay with this person
um
just because
i guess
accept this situation i mean
she respects me she loves me and
uh we have
uh trust and i mean i've been trying to
look through kind of all the things that
are supposed to be in the relationship
and
they seem to be all there so okay so
here's what i want you to do have you
all gone to see somebody and talk about
the
like it feels like you're minimizing it
a lot
and maybe my ignorance on the current
state of treatment for hiv is is the
problem here
it feels like you were worried about
whether this relationship's gonna work
and i'm worried about your health
right
and i think it is of utmost importance
if you are looking at this
person and say i want to spend the rest
of my life with him
i we are in it now and i want to be in
it with with her
you all need to go see
some sort of marriage counselor today
this weekend
monday tuesday next week
go see somebody
and say we're both interested in making
this thing work
and we got this big giant
grenade that just went off in the living
room
right and we got to deal with that
right
yeah and i want you to make sure you are
talking to somebody about your health
your health journey
your parents my guess is you and i could
talk for a long long time about
the messages you received growing up
oh yeah and it was probably tough is
that fair
yes okay
um at some point my hope for anybody is
not that it's when
they have eight contracted hiv and their
parents are telling them that's god
punishing them for making a bad decision
but here you are
at some point you're gonna have to stand
up and disconnect yourself from that
relationship for a season
and ask yourself what do you want to do
professionally what do you want to do
personally
how are you going to cut those strings
and get the
the relational iq relational mental
health healing that you need
and then
lean into am this the person i want to
marry
that makes sense
yeah you're saying oh go ahead
so you're saying that first i need to
like disconnect from my parents like all
my
decisions and everything and then
lean into the relationship and figure
figure that out
no
tim you're 28 right
right what'd you do before nursing
school
um i just had various health care jobs
got my bachelor's in nutrition exercise
and health sciences okay
i'm not going to be the guy here that
tells you you've got a disconnect from
your parents but i'm telling you you got
to grow up
right and yeah that's that's the that's
the idea that i've been
uh
that i've been
or that i had
for i guess in this relationship i did
just tell you to disconnect from your
parents
here's what i mean by that not never
talk to them again
not you sound like a guy that's gonna
follow my my words to a t and so i'm
gonna be really clear with you okay and
it's good for me so i'm glad you're
pushing me on this
you are going to have to make some
decisions on your own you're gonna have
to deal with your family trauma you're
gonna have to deal with the fact that
your parents have told you that the
creator of the universe is punishing you
yeah
and that they don't want their son next
to this woman who did this thing and
what all that stuff
and you're gonna have to reconcile that
with the fact that they love you a lot
my guess is is my guess is that fair
yes okay
you're gonna have to grow up and decide
what you want to do
how you want to do it what battles in
your life are worth fighting
what who you're going to take wisdom and
advice from
do you have close guy friends
uh nothing not very many yeah so one of
the cool things about my job is that
people call and trust me with really
heavy stuff
sometimes and this is one of those
things
where
dude if your girlfriend of a year
gave you hiv
and you don't have anyone else to talk
to in the world that should be a giant
red flag for you you've got to get
people in your life that will walk
alongside you
okay
yeah
a guy a stranger on the radio can't be
your first call here
you've got to have people that you trust
you're 28 that are not your parents that
are your friends
that are a counselor that are people you
work with classmates that you trust
and my tells me that there's just you're
gonna have to practice relationships for
a long time so yes i'm gonna i'm going
back on myself again in the same call i
think i've flip-flopped two or three
times
you do need to disconnect from your
parents but that doesn't mean cut them
off that doesn't mean be ugly or rude or
disrespectful
that means that when they say
god is punishing you for what you've
done you must break up with her and move
home immediately
and you don't want to do those things
you say
i am really grateful that you are trying
to love me in the way you're trying to
love me
i'm 28 i live in my own place
i'm gonna stay here
and i'm gonna make some personal
decisions with the help of a counselor
and a buddy or two um a pastor somebody
that i trust that i can be honest with
and will walk alongside me day after day
about
my romantic relationships my health care
journey
and what's going to come next for me
and i love you guys and i'm grateful
that y'all are speaking into my heart
that's what i mean by disconnecting they
don't get a vote anymore
i understand okay
um
and
you gotta get with you and your
girlfriend gotta give the counselor asap
and you've gotta make a doctor's
appointment if you haven't already have
you seen a traditional medical
practitioner
uh
no please do that
okay
please do that
and i'm not gonna get into your medical
care stuff i i'm not gonna get in all
that other than it says please go see a
traditional doctor okay
please please do that
oh tim
here's how i give you the benefit of
doubt
everything in your world just blew up
your parents your faith your medical
your your health
your relationship with your girlfriend i
get all that in your last year of being
a nurse in the middle of covet
everything in your world is a snow globe
right now just shook up shook up shook
up your cup chicken i get that i get
that i get that
and this call i was not clear on the
skull i'm sorry i was kind of
caught off guard and then surprised and
then trying to work through
word even start on this deal
you need some professional therapeutic
care today asap you need some
professional medical care today asap
backing all the way up to the moon and
looking down on earth
you're 28 years old brother's time to
grow up
time to grow up
life has happened to you
you made some personal choices in your
life about how you're gonna handle
intimacy and sex and how you can be safe
about it and not safe about it
and
there's it happened so now you're gonna
live in that reality and you're going to
work from there
there's not going to be a linear
approach other than medical care and
therapeutic care for sure
there'll be some really good days some
really tough days
and you're going to have to have some
people in your life that walk alongside
you feel free to call me back after you
have some of these hard conversations
brother i'm here to take your calls and
i'll walk alongside with you
i'm not hearing in your voice that you
get what a huge deal this is
this is not about breaking up with your
girlfriend this is every single thing in
your life is different now
and you're gonna have to start from
square one
thank you so much for the trust brother
tim thank you so much for the call get
some people in your life you can talk to
you today that are not your parents but
that will have your best interest and
then we'll walk alongside you and give
you wisdom for the long haul